pray is not a sequel it's not a remake
it has no tire with the with the
original it's you have to look at it
like a reimagining of the of the IP your
board the space station and they're
aliens and you have to survive hurricane
has always the same values in term of
like the kind of games that we make and
a game that we defined as an arcane game
is a game where simulation is very
important where the choices of the
players is very important so we we track
with the dazzle all along with the duel
along so that it can be consequences to
the choices also we give a lot of tools
and because it's all simulated all those
exploring those tools in the in the
environment and against the different a
eyes who put themself assimilated or
they
not owner on the set path they saw all
this combined really provide for
experiences that are unique to each of
the players it's not hard the
psychological real dimension is more
around the theme of identity you know
who are you exactly as Morgan you when
we started the project I wanted to call
him or her Morgan the reason being you
can choose at the beginning of the game
if you are if you want to play a female
or male character and Morgan therefore
is an ideal name because it's new gender
neutral good morning more looks like we
have some tests to run through today the
trailer shows a very brief moments of
encounter with aliens and it is
important to note that it's not just
shooting it's it's it's more like yuh a
hybrid game where the selection
narratives meet with action meets with a
little bit of RPG layer so you have you
have some weapons but you also have lots
of other things including web intervenes
powers that you can learn from
aliens themselves the way you fight
aliens is by either using weapons that
are onboard the station because there is
an entire security on board so it's
logical that there are some weapons but
also you will find some gadgets because
it's a scientist area so there's a lot
of interesting edges because we can use
that I'm not meant for combat but
somehow or a cat in combat if you like
or change games those games that blend
narratives and simulations and some some
choices and a lot of player exploration
prey is going to be that game for you